ننتقل الى مكان المكرمه وهى نصفيان مراسم
مساء العربيه هاني اهلا بك نرسل معك
الاجواء في الحرم المكي في اول ايام الشهر
الفضيل تسمعني يا هاني
نعم اهلا
ايضا اجواء هنا للمعتمرين سوف اخذ معي
مقابله احد المعتمرين ولكن نتعرف على اسمك
السلام عليكم احمد اني من العراق اهلا
وسهلا فيك يا اخوي احمد يعني هذه اول عمره
لا لا الحمد لله جاي قبل يعني كثير يعني
فد عشره عشرين مره كثير يعني من 2018 على
طول اجينا والان يعني ما شاء الله يعني
اجواء جدا رهيبه وحنا نحب أول شي كل عام
وانتم بخير كل عام وانتم بالف خير ان شاء
الله اسال الله ان يعود عليكم وعلى جميع
المسلمين رمضان مبارك الاجواء جدا جميله
واني بالنسبه الي احب اوصل صوت بان اشكر
اداره المسجد الحرام واشكر كل الناس
القائمين على راحته امن الحجاج لان حقيقه
يعني كانوا مبدعين العفو المعتمرين
والحجاج لان التنظيم على اعلى دقه امانه
يعني من كل بمن انك تتكلم عن اعلى دقه
يعني رئاسه شؤون الحرمين الجهات تحدث انه
سخرت الخدمات لكن انت كنت في 2018 بديت
العمره والان وش تشوف الاختلاف والله اشوف
الاختلاف انه اعداد يعني ما شاء الله احنا
ما حج يعني ما شاء الله انا جاي الحاج على
19 يعني قريبا الاجواء من اجواء الحج
والسهوله والمرونه والدخول والله لا لا
ميه ميه حقيقه تنظيم جدا انا ليش الحقيقه
اللي استوقفني انه انا حبيت اسوي وياك
لقاء في سبيل اوصل صوتي بالشكر لاداره
المشاكل لك شكرا شكرا اذا هذا هو حديث احد
المعتمرين هنا طبعا بس بشكل سريع طبعا
الرئاسه شؤون الحرمين هنا في المسجد
الحرام وفرت اكثر من 12 الف شخص يخدمون
هؤلاء الحجاج اليوم رئاسه شؤون الحرمين هي
تطمح بان يصل عدد معتمين في شهر رمضان الى
اكثر من ثلاثه ملايين حاج بخلاف السنوات
الماضيه او بخلاف ما كانت او كانت ايام
العمره قبل ازمه كورونا التي كانت تصل من
مليون ونصف الى مليوني وما اجمل ونحن
نشاهد هذه المشاهد التي تاتينا مباشره من
مكه المكرمه وتحدثنا ايضا عن الخطه وهي
اكبر خطه تشغيليه في تاريخ الحرمين وسط
توقعات ايضا بتدفق الملايين من المعتمرين
نحن نشاهد في ساعه مساء العربيه الاخباريه